we had another insane weekend of the
conspiracy mind virus that is plaguing
the american right wing it's
conspiracies everywhere you look let's
take a little tour through it on the
maria bartoromo program yesterday
morning on fox
marsha blackburn showed up senator
marsha blackburn
and claimed that joe biden is about to
replace kamala harris
which the president can't actually do
but
senator marsha blackburn doesn't seem to
care and of course maria bartoromo now
loves conspiracy theories
senator is there anything you want to
say about kamala harris she was given
the role of acting by the way why is
there music and why does maria bartoromo
have to yell over the music just a tip
production question when joe biden got
his colonoscopy last week colin
yeah
and i i think when you look at what
she has done she has failed at every
task that she's been given that's why
there are many in the white house who
are so frustrated with her it's going to
be interesting to see interesting to see
who they push forward to take her place
what
uh and you know some people in the
comments said oh she's referring to in
biden's re-election in 2024 that's not
what they mean many of them don't even
believe biden's running for reelection
so she's talking about who are they
going to replace kamala with
then we go to something really bizarre
steve bannon appearing on
some kind of very strange it appears to
be a chinese propaganda show it's not
even clear what this is and pushing
vaccine conspiracies about segregation
and very very strange stuff religion and
so i think that this is very powerful
you see every day with the new federal
state remember the new federal state's
only a year and a half old it's only 18
months old and look look look at what's
happened today we're commemorating the
third anniversary of really the rule of
law of the of the great presentation we
had that day at the pierre hotel and
look how much power
uh that the rule of law foundation rule
of law society the whistleblower
movement you've changed history right
here today you can hear the protest in
this city and the protest is about
anti-vaccine
right and it's not that people are
anti-vaxxed is that they're vaccine
hesitant right
and the reason they're vaccine hesitant
is that the information hasn't been put
out about exactly what happened in the
woolhound lab what what is this virus
really about
and why uh therapeutics prophylactic
therapeutics like hydroxychloroquine or
ivermectin or all these other attributes
and what they can do and so the whole
world right now is is questioning
whether it's in europe or in france or
in austria or the united states there's
a big protest here today about about
american citizens who are uh you know uh
american born right who are protesting
the these overreaching mandates to take
what on earth is bannon talking about
take your freedom away so i think if you
look at the new federal state and what
it's been able to accomplish in 18
months and what the
whistleblower movement and what genus
and gtv and particularly the rule of law
just in three years remember it was
three years ago today all right so
there's there's steve bannon uh with um
more anti-vaxx propaganda
we also had a protest a number of d he's
right there were anti-vaccine protests
over the weekend at one of them
the big meme was about
the racism
of vaccine requirements medical
segregation is racist set a sign
stop the mandate before it's too late
this is a new um very often the right
will do this they'll turn something on
its head
and so they'll spend a decade saying
the claims of racism from the left are
bogus
the claims of racism from the left are
racist etc they'll do that and then all
of a sudden they'll say hey actually hey
this is racist something that's not
actually racist vaccine requirements now
are racist
then we go to
alex jones once again at this reawaken
america tour which seems to be going on
every single weekend
here is alex jones taking a sort of
bizarre kind of rapture revelation end
times approach now with the religious
crowd at this event we are literally
seeing the book of revelations begin to
come true right in front of us and this
is the most important time in human
history since christ walked the earth
yeah so this is actually this is getting
very common a lot of these types that
you don't
always
associate with the religious nuttery we
just associate them with the kind of
like more
uh agnostic conspiracy nuttery
they are going in in the direction of
jumping on board with the religious
nuttery um and then speaking of of which
continuing to see trivialization
um of the holocaust at another one of
these anti-vaxx protests i believe this
one in new york city you see another one
of these yellow stars go by and i'll
play that again for our audience you can
see the yellow star kind of near the
penske truck
which says yellow it's a yellow star
that says unvaccinated on it the
continued trivialization of the
holocaust which
is uh just kind of standard operating
procedure at this point point for people
like marjorie taylor green and others so
every single weekend
every single weekend it is conspiracy
after conspiracy we had the sherry ten
penny video
of her saying that vaccinating children
is a late-term abortion
um and that covid testing is torture and
on and on and on and it is getting
really bad i don't know what turns this
around i really don't
uh but it is extraordinarily disturbing